[Music]
are you surviving or
thriving in remote work there are many
benefits to remote work
reduced commute greater employee
flexibility
increased productivity lower operational
costs
and a larger talent pool from any
geography
but working virtually can introduce a
number of new challenges
people can feel out of sight out of sync
and out of mind
collaboration and communication and
building trust
while apart are always much harder
managers in turn
want to motivate their teams they want
to make sure everyone is productive
leading virtually requires specific
practices including
new technologies and strategies
necessary for
leading a remote organization in remote
work revolution for everyone
you will learn to excel in the virtual
work landscape
you will learn how to build trust
increase productivity
use digital tools intelligently and
remain
fully aligned with your remote team by
the end of the course
you will create actionable steps to
relaunch your team
focusing on the new ways to stay
connected
be collaborative and remain productive
while meeting your own personal
and organizational goals remote work is
here to stay and will likely be a
permanent fixture
that transforms many organizations in
one form or another
learn how to thrive in remote work